salut romain savate watts à leur tour
est dans le coup au buzzer je suis un
concert de metallica et donc si tu fais
un truc avec la tête là et je suis tout
point sienne chose promise chose due
c'est aujourd'hui la toute première
vidéo de notre série highway to hell
fest qui va vous aider à préparer au
mieux votre festival de l'été on
commence par une activité bien
spécifique et incontournable du genre
le head banging suivirent les auteurs ou
tour leurs effets
m alors le headbanging pour celles et
ceux qui connaîtraient pas c'est disons
une danse mais qui se pratique
essentiellement avec la tête et les
cheveux alors il ya plusieurs écoles ya
même une multitude de techniques mais
globalement ça consiste à bouger la tête
plus ou moins rapidement et plus ou
moins violemment au rythme de la musique
on peut faire ça d'avant en arrière sur
les côtés en faisant des cercles ou un
peu comme c'est une activité physique
que je qualifierais à la fois artistique
et sportive
donc c'est hyper important de bien se
préparer pour être le plus performant
possible et aussi pour éviter la
blessure je vous arrête tout de suite
parce que je vous vois venir vous allez
me parler de cet allemand de 50 ans qui
a fait un hématome cérébral après un
concert de motörhead ce que vous allez
faire
bon alors oui les médecins ont dit que
c'était probablement lieu web banking
parce que le cerveau quand il bouge dans
tous les sens comme ça il peut se cogner
contre la boîte crânienne et les
médecins estiment que c'est peut-être ce
qu'il a fait saigner
mais qu'on soit d'accord ce pauvre homme
il avait probablement déjà une fragilité
à ce niveau là c'est rarissime comme ça
et comme la jeune fille de 24 ans qui a
fait une rupture d'anévrisme ans n'a
sûrement et puis on en a parlé dans une
vidéo précédente mais les footballeurs
ils peuvent aussi s'abîmer le cerveau en
faisant des têtes bon mais on n'interdit
ni le foot me l'orgasme a priori donc
laissez nous aident bang et tranquille
par pitié bon mais ceci étant dit c'est
vrai que des mouvements répétés comme sa
rapide violent c'est comme tous les
sports extrêmes c'est pas sans danger
dans l'absolu d'ailleurs tom araya le
bassiste chanteur de slayer pour les dom
araya donc qui était un des champions de
la discipline
eh ben il a été opéré des cervicales et
depuis qu'il est privé de être bande il
n'est pas le seul à sept billets coup il
ya aussi des zones yustede l'ancien
bassiste de metallica et nick thompson
le guitariste de slipknot vous imaginez
bien que si les pros en dehors de
problème ça peut aussi arriver
sauf que je suis là et je vais vous
donner deux ou trois conseils pour
pouvoir être bang et à loisir sans
danger et profiter du hellfest jusqu'au
bout et profitez de tous les autres
concerts auxquels vous irez ensuite et
de vos cervicales
alors les risques ça va des douleurs
musculaires au niveau du cou et du dos
parce qu'il est concerné au 6 juin
jusqu'au coup du lapin et vous savez
comment on dit coup du lapin en anglais
whiplash exactement mercy james
et c'est marrant parce que c'est aussi
le nom d'un style doit être bon mais
alors comment on fait pour être bang et
continue d'abord les conseils de base
plus votre corps est fatigué - il
encaisse donc dormez un peu et du coup
si vous êtes au camping pensez à prendre
des bouchons d'oreilles ont fait des
pauses de temps en temps et donc et pas
pendant 72 heures non-stop deuxième
conseil
comme tout bon sportif hydra des
boutiques alors non l'alcool ça
déshydrate l'eau saïd rate donc buvez de
l'eau
ok pas que de l'eau 1 on a en festivals
je suis pas une bête mais entre deux
bières penser en voir un petit peu en
plus avec la gueule de bois et le
conseil technique maintenant le style de
headbanging le moins à même de vous
causer des soucis c'est le full body
en gros les deux pieds plantés dans le
sol les genoux un peuplier et c'est tout
le corps qui bougent pas juste le coup
c'est comme une grande vague qui part
d'en bas et qui se termine au bout des
cheveux a pour second tour du coup
l'effort il est réparti et pas que le
coup clientèle aspirent voilà les trois
petits type ce que je peux vous donner
pour quand vous serez sur place mais
comme on l'a vu
le plus important c'est de bien se
préparer alors voilà quelques exercices
que m'a conseillé mon kiné dont je vous
mets les coordonnées dans la description
si ça vous intéresse et que vous pouvez
faire chez vous le but c'est de
renforcer vos muscles pour bien
stabiliser votre carcasse
on commence par la correction posturale
en attendant c'est un peu avachi comme
ça on va corriger tout ça avec un
exercice très simple vous mettez vos
omoplates vers l'arrière et vers le bas
vous bombay un peu le torse
vous rentrez le menton un peu pas trop
vous grandissez en tirant le sommet du
crâne vers le haut toujours en regardant
droit devant vous voilà et vous tenez
comme ça pendant 5 secondes vous
relâcher et vous recommencez voilà donc
ça c'est la position de base dans
laquelle il faudra faire tous les autres
exercent maintenant on va renforcer les
muscles qui stabilise
pour ça vous vous mettez contre un mur
avec un petit coussin coquet derrière la
tête
sauf s'il a pas la place évidemment et
la pareille vous mettez vos omoplates
vers l'arrière vers le bas vous rentrez
le menton un peu pas trop et vous
enfoncer le coussin derrière votre tête
vous faites des petites séries 2 5
secondes pareil voilà ça c'est pour les
stabilisateurs du coup maintenant on va
s'occuper de la mobilité de votre thorax
ce coup là vous mettez les mains
derrière la tête vous écartez bien les
coudes et puis vous les rapprocher voilà
comme ça et vous recommencez ça
plusieurs fois
ensuite vous tirez les braves vers
l'avant puis vous les étirer en croit
les paumes de main vers l'avant toujours
le regard au loin on termine pour le
haut du corps avec un petit exercice de
renforcement musculaire hyper simple
alors on commence par corriger sa
posture comme dans le premier exercice
omoplates vers l'arrière torse bombé
double menton mais pas trop on grandit
en tirant le haut du crâne et là vous
mettez votre main à plat contre votre
front et vous pousser contre la main
sans plier le coup en gardant la
position de départ pareil en arrière et
de chaque côté voilà et vous refaites
plusieurs sièges et pour gagner
l'ensemble on se fait un petit exercice
qui concerne les abdos et les muscles
profonds que vous connaissez
certainement la planche
là vous vous mettez sur les avant-bras
les coudes à angle droit et sur la
pointe des pieds
attention le dos il faut qu'il soit bien
droit pour être sûr vous pouvez poser un
objet dessus s'il reste en place
c'est bon s'il tombe c'est pas bon vous
regardez toujours droit devant vous
c'est à dire pour le coup le sol et vous
tenez la position alors au début être
compliqué mais rapidement vous allez
pouvoir monter à 30 secondes voire une
minute et l'appareil
vous enchaînez les séries avec un peu de
repos entre chaque
voilà à peu commencé à essayer tout ça
devant un miroir pour être sûr de faire
les bons mouvements
mais un mois avant le hellfest l'idéal
c'est d'intensifier et de faire ça dit
minutes tous les jours bon maintenant
vous avez votre petit programme de
trading perso mais je peux pas vous
laisser comme ça sans de trois conseils
pour le jour de la compet le secret des
champions celui qui permet d'être à la
fois performant et d'éviter les
blessures
c'est fait le dopage
l'échauffement et les étirements avant
de filer vous secouer dans la fosse
petit échauffement des cervicales en
douceur alors vous faites des 2000
cercle vers l'avant puis vers l'arrière
tranquillement
et vous pouvez aussi refaire l'exercice
thoracique vous savez celui avec les
mains derrière la tête et écoute qui
sert et qui s'écartent et le lendemain
matin après la douche
si vous en prenez une harpiste des fois
ya là que non c'est pas la question pour
s'étirer le coup vous baissez les pôles
bien bas vous essayez de poser l'oreille
sur l'épaule et vous tenez 20 secondes
de chaque côté puis pareil vers l'avant
menton rentrée et vers l'arrière en
tirant le menton vers le haut une tortue
les oui on va dire que les étirements
vous les faites le lendemain le soir
mais quartier libre alors si malgré ça
vous avez des petits soucis des petits
vous pouvez avoir prévu d'emmener avec
vous la pommade si baum saint bernard
des contractuels ou une scène que nous
conseillera votre pharmacien ou votre
médecin
mais surtout pour ça comme pour tout le
reste ça me donne l'occasion de vous
rappeler un truc sur le site du hellfest
il ya des secouristes des médecins des
infirmiers donc en cas de vrai problème
fait leurs signaux et oui parce que
détesté c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve donc très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo d'ici là mettez vous
bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]